it's non-stop no it's not don't be too
mad at Disney Jonas Brothers if it
wasn't for them you wouldn't be where
you are today we know you had to say
goodbye and go on your own way but we
know you'll always have a soft spot in
your heart for the mouse eared studio
who gave you your big break we know it
was tough for you before you left Disney
but that's all water under the bridge
now so let bygones be bygones it was a
good run while it lasted
many Disney celebs have had to break up
with Disney over the course of their
careers many of them have a love-hate
relationship with this major studio
while they appreciate the fact that they
got their big break on the disney shows
we all loved they had to part ways here
are the reasons these 10 celebs left the
Disney Channel because nobody knows me
the way that I know me Miley Cyrus Miley
Cyrus got her start on the hit Disney
show Hannah Montana she was a
squeaky-clean Disney teen in the
beginning but after a while Miley said
that was no longer an authentic
representation of who she really was
when she turned 18 she decided it was
time to develop her own identity
Miley said she's anything but a Disney
mascot zendaya zendaya almost left the
Disney Channel at the end of shake it up
when Disney asked her to come back it
was on her terms and she insisted on
diversity Disney listen to Zendaya's
demands and created a show KC undercover
with her as co-producer when KC
undercover ended zendaya decided to move
on to film and television roles she
posted on her Instagram that this was
the end of an era with the end of KC
Undercover brenda song you may remember
brenda song as london tipton in the
suite life of zack & cody she went on to
reprise her role of london tipton for
suite life on deck before landing the
role of Christy Lee on the social
network
she left the safe haven of Disney and
ventured out on shows like scandal and
new girl but after a bit of a break from
Disney she's back and play
the lead role in Disney's animated
series amphibia the Jonas Brothers the
Jonas Brothers have Disney to thank for
catapulting them into stardom they
started out in Camp Rock in 2008
things have changed at Camp Rock and the
sequel in 2010 additionally they had
their own hit Disney Show Jonas they had
a record deal with Disney as well
they were as intertwined as you could
get with the mouse ear studio but
eventually they outgrew Disney and
wanted to do their own thing Joe Jonas
said it can be uncomfortable starring on
the Disney Channel as a young adult
he said they felt boxed in creatively
this Braus twins dylan and Cole Sprouse
starred in Disney's The Suite Life of
Zack and Cody and the suite life on deck
they were considered the most successful
twins since mary-kate and Ashley Olsen
from Full House but things went sour
between the twins and Disney Dylan
shared that Disney tried to steal their
spin-off show idea he also claimed that
Disney denied them producer credits as
well so they parted ways with the studio
bella thorne bella thorne was glad to
move on from disney after being there
first six years on the show shake it up
she shared with Teen Vogue that when she
left the Disney Channel she stopped
listening to other people who were
telling her who she should be she said
she would literally talk in a higher
voice during interviews because she was
trying to uphold this innocent Disney
star vibe but it just wasn't who she
really was
Alyson Stoner Alyson Stoner got her big
break in Missy Elliott's music videos
after that she went on to star in
Cheaper by the Dozen and The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody
she stepped back from the Disney
spotlight after some traumatizing
experiences that she doesn't wish to
talk about she just said that being
famous as a kid is weird and unhealthy
as an adult she recently appeared with
Missy Elliott at the VMAs she still
knows how to work it
debby ryan Disney Channel's Jessi was a
huge hit it starred Debbie Ryan who
helped create the show when she was just
17 years old
our pants on fire after the fourth and
final season of the show Debbie Ryan
shared her plans with Teen Vogue she
said she was going to make being an
actual human a daughter a sister and a
friend her job after the show ended she
said that while she loves to work she
was going to take a little time for
herself
Demi Lovato Demi Lovato opened up to
People magazine about leaving the Disney
Channel show sunny with a chance she
left the show to recover from an eating
disorder after her time in treatment she
decided to focus on her music instead of
her turning to the show she shared that
she didn't think that going back to
sunny would be very healthy for her
recovery she went on to have an amazing
music career so it's clear she made the
right move Selena Gomez this former
Wizards of Waverly Place star said she
left her Disney days behind so she could
be true to herself she said she was
tired of being forced to be a good girl
24/7 so she left Disney and signed a
record deal with Interscope she said
releasing her first record titled
revival was like breathing in a breath
of fresh air which of these Disney
Channel stars is your favorite tell us
in the comments don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to be the first
to see our newest videos and click that
thumbs up button while you're at it
thanks for watching the things we'll see
you soon
[Music]